الم ننصحك من قبل يا ما كنت فرنسا لا مكان
لها في القاره السمراء والافارقه ما عادوا
يطيقونها في النيجر صراع الاقوياء يشتعل
صراع قد يفتح بابا من ابواب الحرب
العالميه ما بين بوتين حصه الاسد من
الساحل الافريقي تتارجح فهي اخر معاقل
باريس تتهد في حضن الدب الروسي وذلك بمعيه
مقاتلي الصحراء ونقصد الجزائر وجميعنا
نعلم انها الحليف الاقرب لموسكو في
افريقيا الاحداث جميعها تطبخ على نار
هادئه ولكن في افريقيا الطباخ الروسي لا
يريدها على نار هادئه
[موسيقى]
ووعيد وخلال اسبوع تبدا الاجتياح فماذا
بعد التهديد يا هؤلاء نحن لا نرى شيئا بعد
ان قالها بوتين هي تحت حمايه وفي الطرف
الاخر القواعد الفرنسيه والامريكيه
تنتظر ساعه الصفر الاصابع على الزناد
والكل يرتعد بوتين يرمي شباكه لاصطياد
قطعه الجاتوه الكبرى بعد النيجر فما الذي
سيحدث ان تصادم الروس والفرنسيون في
النيجر وكيف سيكون شكل هذا التصادم اسئله
نجيب عنها واكثر خلال دقائق هذا الفيديو
تتلاحق التطورات تتبين المواقف تختلف
الصفوف امام الجوهره الافريقيه السمراء
النيجر الحرب تطبق ابواب العاصمه نيامي
الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون لن يصمت
ولن يمسك العصا من المنتصف ويحذر بلهجه
شديده اي صراع عسكري في النيجر سيشعل
منطقه الساحل الافريقي باكملها جدد
استعداده لمساعده النيجر في تجاوز الازمه
الحاليه ونحن امام حاله التاهب القصوى
للجيش الجزائري
العام للقوات في حاله غير مسبوقه بانتظار
ساعه الصفر في الساحل الافريقي دول الساحل
ذات المساحات الشاسعه وعدد سكانها القليل
وصحرائها القاحله في جيوش عاديه لكنها
معتاده على التضاريس الوعيره والداخل الى
تلك المناطق خسران كالعاده تبعد دول هي من
تتقاسم الحدود مع النيجر في مقدمتها
الجزائر وبقيتها هي ليبيا ونيجيريا وبنين
وتشاد ومالي وبوركينا فاسو من هنا عرفنا
بان الحرب في دول الساحل لا تمر مرور
الكرام على الافارقه فمن ذا الذي يرغب
بصراع كهذا الدب الروسي وجها لوجه امام
الديك الفرنسي
ساحه المواجهه بين موسكو وباريس هي النيجر
وليس غيرها وهي الدوله الشركه الاولى
لفرنسا حتى وقت قريب في منطقه الساحل
والصحراء كل ذلك ياتي بعد ان طردت القوات
الفرنسيه بالقوه من مالي وتراجعت بوركينا
فاسو وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وهي بلدان
صارت وثيقه العلاقات مع روسيا نعم لقد
نقلت فرنسا قواتها التي اضطرت للانسحاب من
مال عام 2022 الى النيجر ووافقت حكومه
نيامي على ذلك للاستفاده من الخبرات
الفرنسيه في التدريب العسكري ومكافحه
الارهاب لكن اليوم هذه الحكومه معتقله في
مقرها بينما غرس الانقلاب اوتاده في اواصر
الدوله فرنسا ترى ضروره حمايه صمود النيجر
لكن للنيجريين راي اخر فاستقبلت النيجر
دفعات من مجموعه
والوضع يزداد تازمًا فالحرب وشكه وطرفها
هذه المره هما بوتين وماكون لكن مهلا مهلا
فتصادم باريس وموسكو على ارض النيجر لن
يكون وديا وسيجر المنطقه والدول المجاوره
الى الهلاك لذلك كان الرئيس الجزائري قد
قال بصريح العباره جيشنا قوي وجاهز ولن
نرضى باي تدخل في حدودنا اما ان حصلت
تصادم حقا بين الروس والفرنسيين فلن يكون
اشتباكا مباشر هذه المره بل ستدعم كل دوله
احد اطراف الصراع تحاشيا من اندلاع حرب
عالميه طاحنه وروسيا في صف الانقلاب
ومجلسه العسكري وحكومته الجديده وفرنسا في
كفه الرئيس المعزول محمد بازون وحكومته
وعند كل ميدان يحميدان فهي حرب بالوكاله
يا ساده قليل من الاسلحه الروسيه من هنا
وبعض من الاسلحه الفرنسيه من هناك ولتندلع
المعارك الضاريه النيجر هي اخر معاقل في
الساحل وباريس ستقاتل بلا هواده حتى اخر
جندي النيجري من طرف النظام والروس ربما
بمشاركه بسيطه من فاجنر ومجلس الانقلاب
وحكومته في اتم الاستعداد لاي تدخل خارجي
فرنسا لجات الى مجموعه وجميع رؤساء دول
المجموعه قرار تفعيل القوه الاحتياطيه
ونشرها لاستعاده النظام الدستوري في
النيجر كما قال رئيس كوت ديفوار الحسن
وتارا يتضح شكل الحرب اكثر لكن الامر لم
يحسن بعد ولا زال للقرار بقيه فدول الجوار
للنيجر منقسمه هي ايضا بين مريد لتدخل
اكواس العسكري بهدف اعاده رئيس النيجر
المنتخب محمد بازوم وبين رافض له فالجزائر
اعلنت رفضها واستعداد جيشها لبحر اي تدخل
وبالمثل اعلنت بوركينا فاسو وجمهوريه مالي
استعدادهما لارسال الجيوشهما للدفاع عن
النيجر بالمقابل
عن دعمهما لخيارات الاكواس ولكن الصراع
بين فرنسا وروسيا يراوح مكانه والحربه
تلوح في الافق فقد القت فرنسا بكل ثقلها
لدعم خطط المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا
بالتدخل لمواجهه هذه التهديدات لتعلن
النيجر عن نفسها انها محور الصراع الجديد
بين روسيا وفرنسا وهنا بوتين لن يكتفي بضم
هجر الى قائمه الحلفاء ليضع عينه على
الدول الاكواس كقطعه الجاتوه الكبرى واضع
النيجيريا في المقدمه الكرز على تلك
الجاتوه بانقلاب عسكري في الاكواس او
بايدي فاجنر او باي طريقه كانت بوتين اخذ
قراره كما تقول تقارير العسكريه الغربيه
والرئيس الروسي لا يرجع عن قراره عقوبات
قاسيه والنتائج
لم تمر ايام قليله على انقلاب النيجر حتى
فرض الغرب عقوباتهم للضغط على الانقلابيين
للعوده عن قراراتهم والمتاثر الحقيقي بهذه
العقوبات ليس الانقلاب وانما شعب النيجر
فقد وصلت العقوبات الى حد حرمان البلاد من
الادويه والمواد الغذائيه والتزود
بالكهرباء على الامين الزين رئيس الحكومه
الجديده المعين من قبل الانقلاب يدعو الى
رفع العقوبات غير الانسانيه وغير العادله
التي فرضها الغرب واكواس على النيجر فهي
لم تعد ذات جدوى فقد وقع الفاس على الراس
ولا مجال للعوده الى الوراء لتظهر اول
نتيجه لتلك العقوبات بالخيانه العظمى
وتقويض امن البلاد اتهم الانقلاب الرئيس
المعزول محمد بازون تهمتين غالبا ما
تتراوح عقوبتهما ما بين سجن المؤبد
والاعدام وبعد اعلانهم الانفتاح على
الحوار واستعدادهم الازمه عبر القنوات
الدبلوماسيه عاده الانقلاب في النيجر
يعلنون عزمهم محاكمه بازوم بتهمه الخيانه
العظمى ويؤكدون انهم جمعوا كل الادله
اللازمه لهذه المحاكمه قاده الانقلاب
وافقوا على محادثه
الوزراء المعين اخيرا في نيابه يرحب ببدء
هذه المحادثات لتعود الازمه الى نقطه
الصفر من جديد بعد انفلات الاوضاع عن
السيطره لكن اين ستكون فرنسا وروسيا من
هذا كله
[موسيقى]